quand je danse quand je danse les plats
l'est tout autant qu'à 13 ans qui en
quatrième elle vit à aubigny à côté
d'amiens et son rêve c'était de
rencontrer m pokora
les équipes ont réussi on a réussi donc
à organiser des rencontres avec son
artiste préféré elle était prête à à le
voir ils étaient prêts eux aussi à te
rencontrer le problème c'est que avec
baba noël rien ne se passe comme prévu
regardez tout s'est pas passé comme
prévu
bernard montiel était notre complice sur
cette régalade merci bernard est arrivé
sur le lieu du concert à bien vous avez
fait vivre une belle race rare vous a
fait vivre une belle attaque les deux
parce que vous aussi vous n'étiez pas au
courant je sais qu a reçu un message
très émouvant d'aurélie et ambre en bref
de rencontrer matt pokora alors nous
sommes ici à bien pour que cette
rencontre puisse se faire alors on a
reçu votre message baba noël évidemment
été très touché par ce joli message
mais dis moi si tu rends compte battre
au corps actu appâter va noyer rien tu
vas pas crier
reste ouvert c'est bien écoute on va
essayer de rencontrer pour toi voilà
c'est le cadeau de baba noël ok ok
aurélie à léonie m'a donné avec moi
[Musique]
c'est parti
réalisée on est à quelques secondes de
l'arrivée de beaucoup
comment tu vis à bages super contente
parce que ça fait des années que j'ai
envie de le voir
j'arrive même pas réalisé voilà j'ai
trop est alors aurélie votre fille est
là vous êtes content de l'avoir amené
ici et c'est un m
qui devient réalité c'est bientôt noël
c'est un vrai cadeau noël pour le coup
puis tout petit endroit serait rêve de
le rencontrer donc c'est moi je suis aux
anges
voilà donc c'est formidable et puis je
crois aussi je crois un ccao manning me
semble tu veux tous vous ressentez
quelque chose un équipement plus bas
j'aimerais bien c'est génial d'accord ok
bougeait pas c'est rien ça c'est la
technique savez la télé un c'est
compliqué mais j'espère qu'un paquet la
chasse qui sait
[Musique]
c'est peut-être un imprévu je sais ça
cerbère de merde oui mais non c est pas
bien que ce que je peux faire moi
bon alors je t'explique
tu sais le show business c'est quelque
chose de très difficile m'a trahi
beaucoup tu le sais il est bloqué c'est
ce qui les a motivés agencement est
bloqué à hec et comme ça qui est bloqué
j'ai été envoyé comme un petit message
c'est tellement désolée je suis dégouté
je comprends c'est matt écoute cette
petite vidéo pour te dire que
je suis je suis désolé je devais de
rencontrer aujourd'hui elle a
malheureusement avec tous les problèmes
sur la route là mais concernant les
motions d'arrivée on peut comparer et
voilà j'espère qu'on va pouvoir remettre
sa bonne foi même jour en tout cas moi
je t'embrasse et à bientôt pour une fois
ça lui doit ses minions la vidéo je te
la laisse évidemment où la laisse vidéo
madame je suis vraiment désolé mais non
mais c'est des choses qui arrivent
bon la séquence il faut quand même à
faire c'est une émission qui passent la
semaine prochaine pour battre à noël
comme vous le savez on peut faire des
montages il est arrivé la semaine
dernière avec garou par exemple on fait
un montage un truc vert et on met la
tête de matt pokora
non mais tu t'inquiètes pas tu parlais
pas vraiment parler à quelqu'un on a eu
peur de ce problème depuis ce matin
parce qu'on savait qu'il était bloqué
dans un embouteillage donc on a fait
appel à
alors tu essaies de d'imaginer que c'est
matt et tu ne parles comme si c est mat
tu veux bien tenté le coup bah ouais ça
va bien se passer
kabel voilà je vais rentrer bonjour
voilà maintenant qu'on était pas
attendre tu sais quoi ma chérie essaie
d'imaginer que je suis vraiment désolé
depuis trois jours je sais mais bon ma
chérie alors il ya une première question
alors quelle impression ça te fait de
voir matt comme ça près de toi bats je
suis trop contente qu'ils se réalisent
franchement g13 est ce que tu le trouve
plus beau qu'à la télé ou sur des
posters que tu attends ta chambre
bah oui un vrai basse c'est pas la même
chose que les photos 1
c'est super parce que c'est vraiment le
plus beau jour de ta vie oui
ah oui
on va là ils aient la paix toi qu'est ce
que tu as envie de lui dire je t'adore
jeter suffit depuis longtemps quand même
et
je suis supporter de voir en vrai ben
moi si ça fait plaisir ça rexel toujours
plaisir de voir des fans bien mais qui
nous suit petit peu partout comme ça
alors ory
qu'est ce que ça vous fait aussi de vous
retrouver dans la même pièce que l'idole
de votre finie et bien
c'est étonnant oui oui c'est une
surprise étonnante donc ravis et à la
fois
et à la fois effectivement je vais
remettre à me remettre de mes émotions
là parce que c'est un petit décalage
quand même ma part à penser
effectivement ce qu'on voit sur les
affiches matin beaucoup sur les affiches
de ma fille c'est vrai de vous voir là
avec nous s'est passé c'est un immense
cadeau mer celtique vraiment très gentil
merci d'être venu d'offrir sa machine
est alors battre il ya un truc qu'elle
aimerait faire avec toi c'est chanter
une chanson d'accord la champion de toi
c'est quoi ta chanson c'est là que tu
préfères le plus les planètes les
planètes fraises puis trois seuls dans
ce cas fin du match par les flammes 216
chambres d'hôtel je te rappelle michèle
hirsch pas seuls sur la route entre mes
rêves et mes doutes
l'homme est dur
la piste de danse dernier verre et je
pense à toi quand je dois quand tu
danses
il est planète une auto totaux en farine
oui oui nous attendent ils vont allumer
à une panne c'est pas grave ça va et
après ça on va reprendre juste après
vente et l'entretien ya pas trop blabla
je suis désolé les enfants c'est
vraiment oui
e
ce qui m'est fait rêver attendez on va
reprendre tranquillement les enfants
dis-moi imagine dans ma chérie vraiment
tu vas matt pokora
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un moment vous étiez pas bien
ça vous plaît c'était gênant été arrêtés
décennies rentrée à tous alors voilà
alors regarde cela de vrai c'est énorme
c'est un cadeau de ma voix du coup les
plus timides que tout à leur égard des
profiteuses en bois si tu veux chanter
un petit bout avec lui si tu veux c'est
être au vert j'ai dû chanter le plein
tube c'était son rêve mal ok avec toi
aller quand je danse quand tu danses les
blessures tout au tout nouveau par deux
mois sa différence
je reviens n'est ou lever du jour c'est
ta peau montrer ma poulette crabos
contre ma peau laisse moi les
bull est à pau contre ma peau que ça
seulement sont soumis hier c'était son
rêve alors il ya plus bornés encore non
je danse tendue dans
ans
[Musique]
un mois
indifférent
merci s'il pour tout ce que vous avez
fait parce que c'est aujourd'hui c'est
le rêve de ma fille qui se réalise donc
un gros bisou à toute l'équipe et
1000mercis est joyeux noël
[Musique]